we discussed it yesterday we talked
about it Jim we talked about how Sean
Payton was motivating the Saints to win
three football games by wheeling in the
Lombardi Trophy surrounded by 225
thousand dollars in cash which is the
prize pool money you get for your bonus
money you get from winning the Superbowl
we're wondering you remember we were
wondering how he where do you get the
money from yeah the whole process the
logistics behind it fascinating to me
yeah we we know where he got the money
from okay Charles Davis loaned it to him
Charles Davis and Fox Sports here on the
Rich Eisen show Charles I didn't know
you had that kind of money just lying
around
listen if I had that kind of money I
would be wheeling it into a room of 53
men who would like to add it to their
own collection because I come back that
money would end up staying in there with
the guys I well I'm sure you would have
kept a receipt and things of that nature
the property paperwork yeah what does it
be like a Rodney Dangerfield line right
yeah ooh I tell them that to the bank
done looks good even before we start
over to have to ask yes Joe service the
gates down in the headline yes sir right
did any of the defensive coordinators
especially the NuWave defensive
coordinators in the league weigh in
because if I have a dollar for every
place I go and I hear all gasp no brakes
mmm that's how we want to play our
defense that would have been the
headline all gates no brakes well it's
really all McVeigh Charles right I mean
because it it looks like that deck of a
creeper thirty-two-year-old
well I know I here's the thing is he's
not talking about his coaching tree no
and and I'm already sensing the backlash
like what if McVeigh doesn't win
tomorrow night and all these others are
a badass right and already been asked
our friend Jim Trotter asked it today
and it's a legitimate question and he
made sure he clarified this has nothing
to do with Sean Maday
it's a great respect for me what he's
done is off the charts and Sean and as
you pointed pointing out rich Sean
McVeigh hasn't asked for them it's not
like he's gone around and touted hey you
guys should be hiring all the people
that I've ever said hello to just right
just because plenty of conduct
doesn't win a Super Bowl what does that
say well that's not a fair question for
Shaun McBay just a second year in the
NFL that's a do you know what it says it
says that he has absolutely turned to
Rams franchise around that they would
have had a disappointing finish this
year but does not mean that their next
several years are in the toilet and on
top of all of it you know just because
other teams are giving unproven head
coaches a shot does not mean that
McVeigh didn't come in with a certain
skillset of his own that the Rams
rightly saw and hired on their own right
and it's I don't understand what that
sort of resentment is out there now are
here well let's be honest about it rich
31 32 years old gets his first head
coaching job there's already resentment
then he has the incredible success year
one incredible success year two has a
chance to he's obviously a Super Bowl
contender resentment grows national
profiles on him you watch real sports
and now he's a savant because it
remembers everything which is something
most of us cannot do resentment grows
there's a shot of his girlfriend
resentment quadruples yeah right
resentment goes goes to a factor of 10
and all these things that he's not asked
for he's not presented in that way but
is a natural feel just all of us who
everyone is listening think back to when
you were younger if you were in sports
if you were in band if you're in
whatever and you were the junior of the
senior and a freshman or sophomore
supplanted you you were naturally
resentful that's just how it is
most of us eventually learned how to
handle it but you just are well in this
case that's where we are with Shawn
McVeigh but the one thing I would ask
everyone who's hired all the so-called
Sean McVeigh clones Shawn maybe didn't
just get hired because of offensive
acumen Shawn McVeigh has a presence and
a gravitas to him that you feel when
you're around him he can command a room
of mature adults like few other people
do and at his age you had to be able to
do that I hope
everyone is being hired that was taken
into account can they walk into the room
and make that kind of a make that kind
of a statement with 53 people I guess
we'll find out let's get to the here and
now how do you see the Saturday night
game playing out I'm sure you'll be
sitting there in New Orleans getting set
to call your game like the rest of us
settled in to see the Cowboys and Rams
how do you see a plane out Charles well
I think that the the Rams got their mojo
back a little bit and I realized it was
Arizona and San Francisco down the
stretch but they executed better rich
they looks sharper and Tomic they put
some stuff on tape in those two games
that he hadn't shown much up during the
year
heavier sets more tight ends more
tighter set you know tighter sets at the
line of scrimmage or even Josh Reynolds
was coming inside blocking people you
know running the ball heavily you know
but it both is inside and to the
perimeter the jet sweep said he's been
doing all those things now all on tape a
little bit different some of it than
what he had shown before but to me this
game boils down to this Aaron Donald's
endowment consumer two of the better
pass rushing interior tackles that
you're ever going to find in this game
their job isn't to rush the passer the
job is to hold the line of scrimmage and
make sure there's no gaps for Zeke to
get through if they spend their time
teeing off rushing the passer Zeke will
find space if they hold the point of
attack and let the linebackers fill I
think that takes I'm not gonna say it
takes care of raising because these
phenomenal but it makes it harder for
the Cowboys to to run their offense and
last thing I'll say is dak has got to
use his legs in this game he's got to
pick up two or three first downs with
his feet
both scrambling and on some of the calls
quarterback runs that they haven't done
much of during the year yeah and then we
dig in the Rams conversely after run
Gurley and you know when you said that
they that they looked better last two
weeks
I mean CJ Anderson certainly helped that
coming off the couch and just dominating
in the running game what about golf with
this with this hot boys front seven and
then that back secondary for the Cowboys
that has been just lights out for a
month plus we saw what they did to Drew
Brees we saw what they've done you know
consistently now they have to come on
the road and do it what's your
confidence level in golf coming at
this game Charles my confidence level in
him is pretty good and it rises when
whitworth sullivan flies right that dad
off into front haven stein when those
guys are moving people wanna scrimmage
running it as they did with CJ Anderson
the last two weeks now they do it with
Todd Gurley when that's happening now
he's back to that being that play-action
guy able to settle into the pocket step
in the throws and make them
the one thing I've admired about him
this year in golf is during the bad
stretch when all the criticism came he
was the same guy it never changed and I
know people want to see more urgency and
they want to see him show he was upset
that's not who he is he battled through
it played through it and I believe came
out the other side they have a ton of
weapons but that offensive line for them
which has been intact pretty much for
two seasons the only changes austin
Blythe this year for Jomon Brown two
straight seasons the same offensive line
they're gonna tell the tale in this
whole thing we'll delve into this a
little bit more with Kurt Warner when he
stops by in studio next hour he sat down
with golf and McVeigh for game day
morning our Saturday coverage tomorrow
on the NFL Network if you don't mind
giving a pop for our other employers
right now Charles your game no doubt
your game in New Orleans I mean are you
there yet are you in the body we got
yeah okay
what's it yes we are to buy you headed
headed to Saints practice pretty soon
okay what do you think you're gonna see
on Sunday Charles well look I think we
take 48 to 7 and throw it out the window
I mean it's fun to talk about and I get
it but what you're going to see is it
you know we always like to say what's a
different Eagles team well they're
different in terms of experience on the
back end because that day Sydney Jones
gets hurt at corner right Avante Maddox
gets hurt and he was playing corner and
safety and all of a sudden guys like
Shannon Sullivan Trey Sullivan Craven
Leblanc
Devante Boz B also they're populating
the field they have no cohesiveness the
moment is huge and they're looking at
each other and it was bust after bust
bad play after bad play well in the week
since rich they've had a chance to play
and I think their confidence level was
on real display in Chicago last week
because they made a lot of plays on the
football aggressive on the back end and
the biggest part was you didn't have any
real communication gaps the interesting
part is there's Vic Fangio the new head
coach of Denver one of the most
respected people out there now love Vic
Fangio hard to believe that in a game
like that the bust on defense came from
the Bears with only 10 on the field and
Dallas got us going to touch down you
didn't have down at Philadelphia side
and all of your money would have been on
Cilla Delphia having some communication
gaps it may be giving up some big plays
didn't happen so that's why things are
different more than anything else we can
talk about foals I get it you talk about
all that stuff member jasonkelly got
hurt in that first game to only played
like the first three four snaps so all
this is coming together better for
Philadelphia well they're not a better
team than they were last year okay that
team was better than this one in terms
of where they are right now with all the
injuries and guys being out but they are
more cohesive on the back end so I think
you'll see more of what Jim Schwartz
likes to do rush the front guys play
zone in the back side try not to give up
big plays and see if they can knock a
ball or two free in the secondary and
yet wouldn't you would you agree with
this assessment Saints the safest choice
on divisional playoff weekend out of all
the teams coming off of the by yes or no
yeah exactly I call it saving you look
at the numbers you would say so at home
five and Oh under Peyton and and and and
Drew Brees
they averaged 30 points a game even in
the playoffs I mean with those two it's
which is absolutely incredible and
numbers higher at home yeah you would
say that based on what we're seeing but
I think all of us know that when you're
watching Philadelphia and watching what
they've done down the stretch for the
last month of the season every games
essentially been a playoff game you
don't count them out at all
all right so choose me who's as we wrap
up our conversation here flipping to the
other conference who wins the who's
gonna be in the AFC Championship game
your best guest Rose Davis well I yeah
for me I think the Chargers are going to
go into New England and win why and I
know that's that's crazy because I think
that
it's too trite to say it's Philip Rivers
time but I love their roster and I do
think that on the defensive side Bosa
Ingram Derwin James Desmond King who I
think is perpetually underrated now it
is phenomenal I think they're gonna make
some plays and I'm not quite sure who
the playmakers are in defense for New
England right now I know Gilmore's are
all pro but who makes the plays that
they're used to getting in the past and
you know the names they're rich I think
that definitely them and I do think the
Kansas City finds a way to survive
Indianapolis its Indianapolis is
offensive line which protects luck so
well versus one of the best sack of sack
teams in the league which is Kansas City
if they can drive the ball and not get
sacked
Kansas City's in trouble because they
don't stop anyone couple of sacks maybe
knock the ball free a couple extra
possessions from mahomes
that's why I'm going Kansas City and I'm
saying the Chargers ended up alright
Charles Davis you want to chime in on
the whole Cuyler Murray thing that I had
deejay on yesterday our our draft
compadre yeah now that may ox left us
how dare he
how dare he want to actually be an
actual Darryl manager I mean
Kyler's Mauri first-round selection do
you think I mean DJ said five years ago
three years ago it would have been
laughed at just because of how yeah
height challenged he is I mean what do
you think here Charles yeah I think
these days on target I think that people
going to study it closer than they ever
have before
and it wouldn't surprise me but I would
have a hard time sitting here right now
rich and again keep asking me as we get
closer so I watch him more I still would
struggle with the idea that he'd be like
the first pick of the draft or he would
be my savior right now I see a lot of
plays from him still coming from moving
around which is great but what Russell
Wilson have with Drew Brees had coming
out that we kind of missed along the way
was they were making plenty of plays
from the pocket more so than than what I
think Murray does I hear the screaming
now but this is you know his place in
the pocket against who they were playing
versus what i was expect-- now gonna be
a little bit different so I want to do
I'll study it more believe me but I feel
like this is really an ascent that's
taking place way too fast but that's
just me yeah I think the combine is
going to start with a
huge moment with exactly with him being
measured like what is how just exactly
how tall is he
it's not the most compelling television
everybody waiting for that news what did
he measure yeah that's what they want to
hear that's gonna be the first that's
gonna be the first order of business and
then of course we will all talk about
his draft stock as if the intervening
three months will have nothing to do
with it but you know that's the way it
that's the way that cookie crumbles
Charles thank you for the call
always enjoy chatting with you as you
know kevin burkhart enjoy you and him on
the call do you want to ask the poll
question of Charles before we send him
on on on his way yeah sure Charles which
QB do you most want to see get their
first Super Bowl ring Philip Andrew Luck
golf dak Patrick mahomes Philip time
time in the league presence around there
someone asked me the other day is he a
hall-of-famer and I said of course he's
a Hall of Fame really we didn't want a
Super Bowl and I said okay does that
make Jeff Hostetler hall-of-famer
no offense to Hospit there's got to be
better criteria than that so I'd like
him to get that monkey off his back
I mean Fouts didn't want either means of
course I know that right I know we can
go down that list okay so he got off to
you we got that working for you all
right
Charles thanks for the call appreciate
it thanks a lot you guys be good you bet
that's Charles Davis at CFD 22 the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience